The solution to this problem is x equals 9 7th. Well, let's see how we got 9
7th. Whenever I see an equation with fractions in it, the first thing that I
want to do is get rid of the fractions. Because I don't want to have to add,
subtract, multiply and divide fractions all the way through solving the problem.
To clear the fractions out of an equation, I look at all the denominators, which
I have 6, 2 and 3. And I have to find the least common denominator, because I
want to multiply the entire equation through by the least common denominator.
The least common denominator of 3, 2 and 6 is 6. So, I'm going to multiply the
entire equation through by 6. I have to multiply 6 by each term that is in the
equation. I'm going to write the steps out here. But once you get comfortable,
you can feel free to skip this step. So, I have 6 times 1 3rd, and 1 3rd is
being multiplied by 2 x minus 1. On the right side of the equation, I have 6
times negative 1 half x plus 6 times 7 6th. When I multiply 6 times 1 3rd, I get
6 times 1 3rd is 6 over 3, which gives me 2. And that's going to be multiplied
by 2 x minus 1. On the right side of the equation I have 6 times negative 1 half
x. 6 over 2 is 3, so I have negative 3 x. When I multiply 6 times 7 6th, the 6th
cancel out and I'm left with a 7. Once I clear the fractions from the equation,
I need to distribute wherever needed. Here, I have 2 times 2 x minus 1, so I
need 2 times 2 x, and I need 2 times negative 1. 2 times 2 x is 4 x, and 2 times
negative 1 is negative 2. And I just write down the other side of my equation.
Once I've cleared the grouping symbols and distributed where needed, I would
combine like terms on each side of the equation. However, here, there's only one
x term and one constant term on the left side, and one x term and one constant
term on the right side. The next step is to move all my constants to one side of
the equation. We learned that whatever you do to one side of the equation, you
have to do it to the other side of the equation. So, if I add 3 x on this side,
I have to add 3 x on this side. When I add 3 x to both sides, I have 4 x plus 3
x gives me 7 x minus 2 equals negative 3 x plus 3 x is 0. So, I just have 7. Now
that I have the variable on one side of the equation, I need to move the
constant to the other side of the equation. When I add 2 to both sides of the
equation, I get 7 x on the left side. Negative 2 plus 2 is zero. And I get 7
plus 2 which equals 9 on the right side. So, I have 7 x equals 9. The last step
is to divide both sides of the equation through by the coefficient of the
variable. The coefficient of the variable is 7, so I divide both sides by 7. 7
over 7 is 1, so I have x equals 9 7th. Solving an equation with fractions in it
is a little bit more difficult. But if we simply multiply through by the least
common denominator, all the fractions dissappear and you're left with a simpler
problem to solve.